para pensar
he vendido a la vecina presentación que
acabamos
y si no existe que acabas de sentir
como podría sentirse
una persona sorda que utiliza la lengua
de señas mexicana
todos los días en una sociedad de
oriente
veamos si puedes entender un poquito
mejor
hola
es y olivas
hoy vamos a hablar
algunas personas solas en el vecino
vemos segundos de comunicación que
existían
ese niño
vemos como al entregar el mensaje
d
mexicana
pero vamos a hacer
vemos como esa
voy a comprender
necesitan las personas sordas
no se diga que me condenen
quizá que favorecido
alexis pieza
y digo
a veces
bueno
el mismo oyente hablarlo de su vida
practicando de manera natural una
regresión objeto palabra
para una relación significado
significante
el signo lingüístico está compuesto por
en sangre habilidad de los conceptos el
significado y el civilidad
con la imagen acústica
explicado
mi cabeza
pero irremediablemente
entonces el oyente
al escuchar y todos los días
entonces gente de disney
entonces
bueno
se refiere a este líquido blanco
delicioso
entonces
cuando esto sucede empieza a adquirir un
montón de conceptos e imágenes mentales
las primeras palabras de los niños
alrededor de los 10 o 12 meses en
palabras mismas
sin embargo de antes
viviendo esta relación
aprendiendo que todas las cosas tienen
un mango
vemos la importancia de esto cuando
vamos a la escuela
de la sardina
y
esta es la característica que esto
proyecto logra es crear la relación
significado significantes
y es natural
veamos qué pasa entonces con eso
a eso
qué significa que es el militante fuerte
poder
para que pueda desarrollar habilidades
productivas de aprendizaje
en una mente llena de imágenes mentales
y en conceptos de información mientras
mínimamente
d
sabes
dime
los mismos conceptos
20 duración de esta manera
no es eso
me voy a quedar aquí
ese va a ser el significante del día
pero la relación significa base
militante rival el niño a la gente y
poder dar una mente llena de conceptos
llena de abstracción
en expresión 4
veas
creo que es importante mencionar conocer
y es la discapacidad auditiva
se conoce como la disminución
pero va más allá
vemos como en igualdad de oportunidades
del niño
bueno
de información de una manera visual
desarrollar habilidades
sólo en la cultura
sus monitos son servidos pero ahora
y los tienen con mis de mayúscula porque
no aportan nada
qué pasa
todos tenemos infancia
este lenguaje
en el oriente desde viena te está
escuchando salida de esa relación
maravillosa de signos lingüísticos y
estableciendo
sabemos de diferente manera con el niño
sano
sí
y también
soy un articulador está en casa
entonces vuelves
y entonces
y no
o no
no
entonces en el proceso de aprendizaje
tenemos
entonces
mientras panistas
y muchas de las acciones no tienen
presentados existen
ansioso
sí
y hay
y entonces
como los idearios
y ese tipo de precisión de lenguajes
mejor
entonces
y entonces
ah
sí
la lengua
con lengua física
con mis ahorros
sí sí
sin la velocidad de mexico
estamos juntos
pero sé que este tipo de esperar y
perder esos lugares de mi decisión
es un 9 en el año 1860
antes
los dolientes dijeron
no verdad
funcionar
y vamos a ver
nos agradecerán
veinte hombres 20.000 congresos
y estamos
en el qué
mexicana
como caminar el mismo darse
de 40 2005 pasar
siete años
de una comunidad tan hermosa como la de
mis horarios para reconocer
mi casa
maestro para llenar la venta de tu niño
cerró de conceptos de signos a la casa
de tus niños oyentes
hay miles de artículos hay poblaciones
esas personas
del gobierno estatal
esto se debe a que en cada aula
en el camino solo
el signo lingüístico
en la vez
s
cuando quiera
entonces
quisiera
de eeuu
sí
las personas sordas
lo mismo que las siguientes
es cierto escuchar
entonces
ciudades que enseña la ciudad